PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA SPEAKING
AT THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
COMMITTEE JEN.
FOX WILL HAVE COVERAGE OF ALL OF
IT.
FORMER DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE
MARIANNE WILLIAMSON HAS BEEN
FOLLOWING IT CLOSELY.
SHE DESCRIBES THE EXPERIENCE AS
LIKE "BINGE WATCHING A MARRIOTT
CONGRESSIONAL.
THAT SOUNDS ABOUT RIGHT, PRETTY
UNAPPETIZING.
SMOTHERED IN THE
THICK SAUCE OF SELF SELF SELF
RIGHTEOUSNESS AND SELF-PITY.
SO FAR, THE MAIN EXCITEMENT HAS
BEEN WATCHING JUST HOW
SHAMELESSLY THEY CAN LIE.
THE GOAL APPEARS TO BE COMPLETE
REALITY INVERSION.
PROFESSIONAL RICH LADY
MICHELLE OBAMA TOLD AMERICA SHE
WAS OPPRESSED.
THE CRIMINALLY NEGLIGENT
GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK BRAGGED
ABOUT HOW WELL HE HANDLED THE
CORONAVIRUS AND
JEFFREY EPSTEIN’S OLD PAL
BILL CLINTON SHOWED UP JUST
BECAUSE THE PARTY’S MORAL VOICE.
THERE’S BEEN A LOW GRADE THRILL
AND WATCHING ALL OF THIS.
THEY DON’T TELL SMALL LIES IN
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THEY GO
ALL THE WAY.
YOU CATCH THEM STEALING YOUR
WALLET AND THEY ARREST YOU FOR
THEFT AND GIVE YOU A LECTURE
ABOUT HOW CRIME DOESN’T PAY.
THE LONG TIME STUDENTS OF THE
LIBERAL MIND, NONE OF THIS IS
NEW.
THE LEFT LONG AGO BUILT AN
ENTIRE POLITICAL PARTY BASED ON
THE FREUDIAN PRINCIPLE OF
TRANSFERENCE, DISPLACE THEIR OWN
SINS ON TO YOU, THEREBY
CLEANSING THEIR CONSCIENCES AND
ALLOWING THEM TO SEIZE THE MORAL
HIGH GROUND.
IT’S A CLEVER TRICK BUT AT THIS
POINT IT’S AN OLD TRICK, WE KNOW
HOW IT’S DONE.
THE PUBLIC CERTAINLY SEEMS TO
HAVE FIGURED IT OUT.
LAST NIGHT, THE DEMOCRATS
CONVENTION LOST IN THE RATINGS
TO A VARIETY SHOW CALLED
""AMERICA’S GOT TALENT"."
A PAIR OF JUGGLERS FROM THE
PHILIPPINES, BROTHERS WEARING
GLOW-IN-THE-DARK HEADBANDS DID A
YO-YO DEMONSTRATION ON STAGE AND
THAT OUT RATED DR. JILL BIDEN BY
A LOT.
I COULD’VE TOLD YOU THAT WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN.
ONLY NICOLE WALLACE WANTS TO
WATCH ANOTHER SPEECH BY DR. JILL
BIDEN AND BY THE WAY, WHAT KIND
OF DOCTOR IS SHE?
SOME OF US AREN’T FEELING WELL.
WITH THE DEMOCRATS SHOULD HAVE
DONE IS PUT THE REST OF THEIR
PROCEEDINGS ON TV.
THAT WOULD GET AN AUDIENCE.
YOU MIGHT NOT KNOW THIS BUT MOST
OF THE ACTUAL CONVENTION EVENTS
TAKE PLACE DURING DAYTIME HOURS.
THE NETWORKS DON’T COVER THEM,
YOU HAVE NO IDEA THEY EVER
HAPPEN.
THERE’S A REASON FOR THAT,
OBVIOUSLY, BUT WHAT A LOSS FOR
THE VIEWING PUBLIC.
IF YOU SAW WHAT THEY WERE SAYING
DURING THE DAY, YOU WOULD NEVER
TUNE INTO PRIME TIME AGAIN.
YOU MIGHT FLEE THE COUNTRY.
FOR THE LAST THREE DAYS WE HAVE
WATCHED ALL OF IT.
IN A MOMENT WE WILL SHOW YOU
WHAT WE FOUND.
WE WANT TO BEGIN THIS EVENING BY
BRINGING YOU A MOMENT OF PRAYER
THAT BROKE OUT AT THE CONVENTION
ON MONDAY.
A PASTOR CALLED FREDERICK HAYNES
TOOK THE MICROPHONE.
COMPARED TO WHAT YOU MIGHT HEAR
IN YOUR OWN CHURCH.
>> YOU HAVE THE NERVE TO BUILD A
WALL WHILE AT THE SAME TIME YOU
HAVE IN THE HARBOR THERE IN
NEW YORK THE STATUE OF LIBERTY
SAYING "GIVE ME YOUR TIRED, YOUR
HUDDLED MASSES YEARNING TO
BREATHE FREE."
WILL SAY AMERICA, IF YOU DON’T
GET YOUR ACT TOGETHER YOU MAY
WELL GO TO HELL.
>> Tucker: VOTE FOR BIDEN,
DOOM CENTERS, OR YOU ARE GOING
TO HELL.
THAT’S A PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD
MESSAGE.
DESPITE WHAT YOU MAY HAVE HEARD,
IT IS THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY THAT
IS A HOTBED OF RELIGIOUS
EXTREMISM THESE DAYS.
A FAN OF MINISTER LOUIS
FARRAKHAN, MEN OF FAITH.
JUST NOT YOUR FAITH.
BUT RELIGION IS NOT THE ONLY
INSTITUTION THE DEMOCRATS ARE
RECONFIGURING AT THEIR
CONVENTION, THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE COULD USE AN
OVERHAUL, TOO, THEY’VE DECIDED
AND THEY ARE GIVING IT ONE.
WATCH THE NEW VERSION.
>> I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
AND FOR THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH
IT STANDS.
ONE NATION, UNDER GOD,
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
SOMEDAY.
>> Tucker: SOMEDAY, RIGHT.
SOMEDAY THIS COULD BE A GOOD
COUNTRY.
SOMEDAY IF WE ARE IN CHARGE.
OTHERWISE IT’S AN AWFUL PLACE.
WITHOUT US AT THE HELM, AMERICA
IS TERRIBLE AND NOT WORTH
SAVING.
YOU’VE HEARD THIS BEFORE.
MICHELLE OBAMA WANT TO ONCE
SUGGESTED IT.
THE FIRST TIME SHE WAS PROUD OF
HER COUNTRY WAS WHEN HER FAMILY
GOT AROUND IT BUT THAT WAS
NUANCED BY THE STANDARDS OF
TODAY.
AT THE DEMOCRATIC CONVENTION
THIS WEEK, TRANSGENDER RIGHTS
ACTIVIST CAME OUT AND SAID IT
EXPLICITLY.
>> I’VE NEVER FELT AMERICAN, I
DON’T KNOW THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE, THOSE ARE NOT MY
SYSTEMS, THAT IS NOT MY
PRESIDENT.
>> Tucker: THOSE ARE NOT THEIR
SYSTEMS, DONALD TRUMP IS ANOTHER
PRESIDENT.
THIS IS NOT THEIR COUNTRY AS
LONG AS THEY DISLIKE THE GUY IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
SO IT’S ALL OR NOTHING FOR THEM
AND RIGHT NOW THEY ARE TRENDING
TOWARD NOTHING WHICH IS WHY THEY
APPARENTLY TURNED OVER THE D&C
STAGE DIRECTIONS TO
COLIN KAEPERNICK, WATCH.
>> MANY OF THE VIDEOS AND
PICTURES YOU ARE ABOUT TO SEE
WERE RECORDED BEFORE COVID WHICH
IS WHY THE KIDS ARE NOT SOCIAL
DISTANCING.
HOWEVER THE AUDIO WAS RECORDED
OVER THE PAST MONTH.
YOU MAY RISE OR KNEEL IF YOU ARE
ABLE OR YOUR PREFERENCE.
>> Tucker: YOU CAN KNEEL.
SO IF YOU WATCH THIS STUFF FOR
LONG ENOUGH, AND WE HAVE, IT’S
PRETTY EASY TO FORGET IT’S
PRETTY KAREN ACTUALLY, MOST AMER
LIKE THEIR COUNTRY, THAT’S WHY
THEY LIVE HERE AND A LOT OF THEM
DISPLAYED THEIR AFFECTION BY
STANDING FOR THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM.
IT MEANS QUITE A BIT TO PEOPLE.
AMERICANS HAVE DIED IN BATTLE TO
PROTECT OUR NATIONAL SYMBOLS.
THAT’S A TALKING POINT BUT IT’S
NOT JUST A TALKING POINT, IT
REALLY HAPPENED.
BUT THEY DON’T KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT THAT OF THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL CONVENTION AND THEY
DON’T THINK YOUR KIDS OUGHT TO
KNOW ABOUT IT EITHER AND THAT’S
WHY THEY’VE ENDORSED ERASING
AMERICAN HISTORY.
>> ME THIS MOMENT IN HISTORY
MANIFEST MORE MONUMENTS LIKE
THESE THAT REPLACE THE OLD ONES
THAT NO ONE CARES TO SEE
ANYMORE.
MAY THEIR EMERGENCE OF A MORE
OVERDUE ESTABLISHMENT AND
EXISTENCE REMIND EVERYONE OF OUR
TERRIBLE, UGLY, AND HURTFUL
BLACK WORLD HISTORY.
>> Tucker: SO THERE ARE PARTS
OF HISTORY NO ONE CARES TO SEE
ANYMORE SO WE ARE GETTING RID OF
IT.
IF YOU’RE KEEPING TRACK AT HOME,
IF NOT, WE ARE AT A RACE IN
AMERICAN HISTORY, REWRITE THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE, MOCK AND
DEGRADE THE NATIONAL ANTHEM,
TURN CHRISTIANITY INTO A
POLITICAL WEAPON.
THEY HAVE BEEN BUSY OVER THERE
AT THE DNC BUT THERE’S MORE
BECAUSE NOW IT’S TIME FOR SOME
GRANULAR POLICY DISCUSSIONS, THE
DETAILS OF HOW TO RUN THE
COUNTRY.
WE’VE SHOWED YOU IN PREVIOUS
NIGHTS THIS WEEK SOME OF THE
DNC’S PLATFORM, THEY WANT TO GET
RID OF A LOT OF THE COUNTRY’S
PRISONS, FOR EXAMPLE, DO AWAY
WITH BAIL FOR ACCUSED CRIMINALS.
BUT THAT’S JUST THE START.
WE ARE GOING TO GO TO SOMEONE
NOW, YOU SHOULD KNOW THAT JAY
MY’S PREFERRED PRONOUNS ARE
THEY-THEM.
CURRENTLY LIVING OUT THEIR EVER
EVOLVING TRUTH IN WINSTON-SALEM.
GOD IT?
OKAY.
NOW LISTEN.
>> WHY CAN’T FOLKS IMAGINE A
WORLD WITHOUT THE COPS, WHY
CAN’T FOLKS IMAGINE A WORLD
WITHOUT PRISONS, WHY CAN’T
PEOPLE EXPAND THEIR IMAGINATIONS
TO INCLUDE COMMUNITY CARE,
INCLUDING ABOLITIONIST FUTURE?
I’M TALKING ABOUT FOR REAL, FOR
REAL ABOLITION, NOT JUST WATER
DOWN DNC VERSION OF ABOLITION,
TALKING ABOUT ABOLISHING THE
POLICE, TALKING ABOUT ABOLISHING
ICE, ABOLISHING PRISON.
>> Tucker: ABOLISHING POLICE,
ABOLISHING ICE, ABOLISHING
PRISON, WE ARE IMAGINING A WORLD
LIKE THAT.
YOU’RE STARTING TO GET SOME
SENSE OF WHY THEY ARE NOT
PUTTING THE STUFF ON TV,
DEMOCRATS AND THEIR FAITHFUL
LACKEYS THE MEDIA HAVE BEEN
TELLING YOU FOR WEEKS THAT NONE
OF THIS IS REAL, YOU’RE
IMAGINING IT.
DEMOCRATS DON’T REALLY WANT TO
TAKE THE COPS AWAY AND LEAVE YOU
DEFENSELESS.
YES, THEY ARE VOTING TO TAKE
BILLIONS FROM POLICE DEPARTMENT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY BUT THAT’S
NOT REALLY DEFUNDING, IT’S
REDISTRIBUTING.
NOT A BIG DEAL, CALM DOWN.
BUT NOW, JAY MY SHOWS UP AND
LETS AN ENTIRE ANIMAL COUNTER OF
CATS OUT OF THE DNC’S BAG AND
SAYS THAT ALL YOUR FEARS ARE
TRUE.
BE SURE TO WARN YOUR DAUGHTERS,
NO MORE FIELD HOCKEY
SCHOLARSHIPS FOR THEM.
THERE ARE BOYS ON THE FIELD.
DEMOCRATS WANT BIOLOGICAL MEN TO
COMPETE WITH GIRLS IN SPORTS.
MOST PARENTS OF GIRLS THINK
THAT’S NUTS BECAUSE IT IS AND
TERRIBLE FOR GIRLS BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY.
BUT AT THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
CONVENTION, IT’S NOT EVEN
QUESTIONED.
IT’S JUST BUSINESS AS USUAL.
WATCH TRANSGENDER PERSON MARISSA
RICHMAN EXPLAIN.
>> A PANEL LOOKING AT YOUTH
ISSUES WHERE WE’VE BEEN WATCHING
STATE LEGISLATURES ESPECIALLY
HERE IN THE SOUTH TARGETING
TRANS YOUTH, TRYING TO DENY THEM
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE, EDUCATION
AND EVEN ACCESS TO THE RIGHT TO
PLAY SPORTS ALTHOUGH NEEDLESS TO
SAY, THE MISHANDLING OF THE
CORONAVIRUS BY THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION IS AFFECTING A
LOT OF PEOPLE’S ABILITY TO PLAY
SPORTS.
BUT THEY HAVE BEEN PARTICULARLY
TRANSPHOBIC IN SCHOOLS.
>> Tucker: OKAY, NO MORE FIELD
HOCKEY SCHOLARSHIPS AND I’M
SORRY YOUR DAUGHTERS ARE NOT
GOING TO MAKE THE SOCCER TEAM.
THAT’S BAD NEWS, MOST PEOPLE
COULD LIVE WITH THAT IF THEY HAD
TO.
BUT ONCE AGAIN, IT’S JUST THE
BEGINNING.
WHAT IF THEY ABOLISHED
CAPITALISM, TOO?
WOULD YOU LIKE SOME BREAD LINES
TO GO WITH THAT?
HOW ABOUT SOME HUMILIATION ON
THE SIDE?
LISTEN TO ASPIRING ECONOMIST
ASHLEY NICOLE McRAE.
>> THE FUTURE WE ARE ALL TRYING
TO BUILD REALLY IS ABOUT THE
DESTRUCTION OF COLONIZATION,
WHITE SUPREMACY AND CAPITALISM.
>> Tucker: THE DESTRUCTION OF
COLONIZATION, WHITE SUPREMACY,
AND CAPITALISM.
WHAT IS THAT MEAN, EXACTLY?
WE ARE NOT SURE, WE ARE NOT
DELEGATES TO THE DNC BUT WE’RE
PRETTY CERTAIN IT’S GOING TO BE
BAD NEWS FOR YOU.
BUT NOT THE END OF THE BAD NEWS.
NO, THERE’S MORE.
ELIZABETH WARREN SHOWED UP TO
SPEAK AT THE NATIVE AMERICAN
CAUCUS ON TUESDAY.
SEEMS PRETTY LIKELY SHE’S COME
TO STEAL YOUR HORSES.
>> JOIN US IN FIGHTING FOR
JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS AND
IN SUPPORTING THE DEMOCRATS SO
THAT WE CAN ALL CONTINUE OUR
WORK FOR INDIAN COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: IT’S JUST SO GREAT.
OUR WORK FOR INDIAN COUNTRY.
WE KEPT WAITING FOR RALPH
NORTHERN TO SHOW ABOUT THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN PANEL WEARING A
HOODIE.
PEOPLE ONLINE LOVE TO THE WARREN
PANEL.
PEOPLE AT HOME FLOODED THE DNC
WITH SUGGESTIONS FOR CHIEF
WARRANT.
IF ELIZABETH WARREN CAN SPEAK AT
A NATIVE AMERICAN EVENT, MAYBE
MILLI VANILLI CAN HOST THE
GRAMMY AWARDS.
BUT IT HURTS ELIZABETH WARREN’S
FEELINGS SO THE DNC SHUT DOWN
THE CHAT ROOM, WHAT A SHAME.
IT BEARS REPEATING THAT NOT ALL
THIS INSANITY WAS CONFINED TO
THE DAYTIME, SOME OF IT BLED
INTO A PRIME TIME AS WELL.
SANDY CORTEZ SHOWED UP.
SHE DID ALL OF THAT IN A 92ND
SPEECH, PRETTY IMPRESSIVE.
IT WAS LIKE A SOCIALIST MAD LIBS
COMPETITION, HERE’S PART OF IT.
>> THANK YOU TO EVERYONE HERE
TODAY ENDEAVORING TOWARDS
BETTER, MORE JUST FUTURE FOR OUR
COUNTRY AND OUR WORLD.
IN FIDELITY AND GRATITUDE TO
AMASS PEOPLE’S MOVEMENT WORKING
TO ESTABLISH 21ST CENTURY
SOCIAL, ECONOMIC, AND HUMAN
RIGHTS, INCLUDING GUARANTEED
HEALTH CARE, HIGHER EDUCATION,
LIVING WAGES, AND LABOR RIGHTS
FOR ALL PEOPLE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
I HERE BY SECOND THE NOMINATION
OF SENATOR BERNARD SANDERS OF
VERMONT FOR PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
>> Tucker: LET’S PUT HER IN
CHARGE, THAT’S A GOOD IDEA.
WE SHOULD KNOW TO THAT CRAZY AS
ALL OF THIS WAS, AND IT WAS,
NONE OF IT WAS TOO CRAZY FOR
JOE BIDEN OR KAMALA HARRIS.
SANDY CORTEZ CALLED FOR GIVING
GOVERNMENT HEALTH INSURANCE TO
FOREIGN NATIONALS, IMAGINE A
WORLD WITHOUT COPS OR PRISONS,
SOME LUNATIC IN A CLERICAL
COLLAR SAID REPUBLICANS ARE